muito boa tarde eu vou dedicar essa
música quero toda a classe trabalhadora
ou quem aí aí aos quatro extremos de são
paulo zona leste norte sul oeste centro
nordeste norte dedicaram toda costa e
trabalhadora
aí a trabalhadora voltando pra casa
perguntando pra deus porque não tenho
asas para voar pelos ares de voltar para
o lar real o dem possui o dói só de
pensar na bolsa um livro novo não tem
condição
leitora na multidão frustração 9 horas o
trabalho é bem mais suave que as duas
horas balançado da competição
o dia inteiro tentando touro uma volta
cansativa ainda desce pelo ponto mais
escuro a violência subindo de nível do
receio da multidão a sensação da mulher
é horrível ela caminha semblante
preocupado escuridão o bar da rua se
encontra fechado quanto vale uma vida
pensando sempre vert na bolsa tem a
bíblia também tem canivete passar o
beque o brega de perecer mas ela sabe
que o pior pode acontecer na madrugada
pelo bairro impera o solo no rolo poste
quebrado matagal abandonando se ela
traga seu dinheiro será descontado e
afirmou metros oferece um ônibus fretado
jesualdo beckett como brasa só para
relaxar quando entrar dentro de casa ou
o
é hora de voltar pra casa o trabalhador
só que chega bem infelizmente não tem
asas e precisa das duas vidas linhas do
trem a condução está tão cara
conforto é algo que não tem mas o
trabalhador encara essa rotina sem nunca
depender da casa portanto do trampo a
faculdade o corpo exausto apesar da
pouca idade sem novidade abc da rota
tentando ser um povo solidário com boas
notas trabalhar estudar nem sempre se
encaixa
nem mesmo no fim da aula o aluno relaxa
pensa na volta no clima lá fora o metrô
não funciona por 24 horas logo vem à
mente os lençóis de fusão vai parando
nos pontos e dos guarda-sóis referir a
esse desafio manhã é de rondon ti raro
um busão brasil ele se adianta violência
espanta sua família se gosta ou espera
para janta a madruga é tensa quando um
estouro canta amanhã já pensa coisas
dawn nó na garganta ro o perigo e todos
os lados quanto mais dinheiro
vivem mais resultados a violência na
cidade tem se espalhado se isola mais
ainda que tem um carro blindado andando
com cuidado os espaços apertados receio
de sofrer o abuso de um homem fardado
chegando em casa ele se sente mais
aliviado
recebido com o calor de um abraço
apertado ou o na hora de voltar pra casa
trabalhado só quero chegar bem
infelizmente tão tem asas e precisa das
suas vidas minhas o trem a condução está
tão cara conforto algo que não tem mas o
trabalhador encara essa rotina sem touca
depender de ninguém
[Música]
i
aí é muito obrigado
[Aplausos]